noah manoir bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec fierté france alors on l'a
vu un beaucoup de monde cet après midi
dans les rues de paris un important
dispositif policier est également mise
en place du côté de la police est ce
qu'on craint des débordements côté je
n'ai pas accès comme vous le savez aux
informations du préfet de police ni à
ses prévisions mais je pense
qu'effectivement en toute logique il
faut noter le mécontentement général
on est quand même en période dans un
contexte si vous les sanitaires qui
théoriquement devrait limiter le nombre
de sorties de participation à des
rassemblements quels qu'ils soient et
les gens sont tellement en colère qu il
brave justement tout les jeunes et
toutes les recommandations et ils
sortent pour prendre le pavé pour
exprimer leur mécontentement
donc il faut se dire qu'aujourd'hui si
on a plusieurs milliers de personnes
voire plusieurs dizaines de milliers sur
la place de la bastille ça voudrait dire
peut-être plusieurs centaines de
milliers dans un contexte plus plus
normal c'est-à-dire en dehors de 2,2 du
contexte épidémique et sanitaires donc
je crois qu'il ya un mécontentement qui
est tout à fait justifiée à mon sens et
je sens une certaine au regard des
déclarations qui ont été formulés par le
ministre de l'intérieur mais également
par le président ait vu que même une
crainte si vous voulez cette affaire
messieurs d'éclairs c'est une affaire en
réalité rodney king à la française qui
pourrait
en dehors de ce contexte syndicats je le
répète provoqué des émeutes ethnico
racial sur le territoire j'ai toute
confiance en nos concitoyens pour sûr et
prendre la mesure de ce qui se passe et
faire confiance à notre justice mais il
faut faire très attention ne peut pas
faire on peut pas s'aventurer comme le
font certains arrêtent pas de syndicaux
de la police a tenté de justifier ce qui
s'est passé par le passé lointain de la
victime et vous noah manoir en tant que
policier est ce que vous sentez visé par
ce mécontentement que vous définissiez à
l'instant mais vous savez que chez vigie
on a une politique et une éthique qui
sont à contre courant de ce qui se fait
dans les autres organisations syndicales
donc nous même si on est minoritaire
dans la profession on bénéficie quand
même d'un large soutien populaire et
donc on se sent pas du tout visé mais on
a beaucoup de collègues de bonne foi qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas exprimer
justement leur dire leur indignation
face à ce qui s'est passé parce que vous
savez
bertha dans la police qui n'est pas
nouvelle qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
dans laquelle se dresser contre
l'institution contre les traditions
contre les dogmes inhérents justement à
la pratique du maintien de l'ordre
également c'est s'attirer des ennuis
vous savez que mais pas sans savoir qu
alexandre langlois même avoué que
sanctionner donc ça donne pas envie aux
autres de suivre le même chemin de donc
je crois qu'il ya un travail de fond à
faire au niveau de huit salles
intérieures et ça on peut vont pourra
pas faire l'économie à un moment ou un
autre
d'ignorer le discours des organisations
syndicales qui ne sont absolument pas
représentative du droit et du bon sens
un même si
elle recueille un certain nombre de
votes dans la profession pour des
raisons qui sont plus des raisons liées
aux intérêts personnels qu à l'éthique
professionnelle
ils ont le et donc s'ils voulaient cette
loi est une aberration l'article 24 de
cette loi est à proscrire justement pour
la liberté pour le contrôle citoyen et
pour le service public en général la
police n'a rien à cacher
quand elle n'a pas de pratiques hors la
loi et quand elle pratique son travail
dans le centre de l'intérêt général
et qu'est ce que vous entendez vous dans
les commissariats par exemple à côté de
la machine à café
qu'est ce qui se dit chez chez vous
aussi vos collègues par rapport à la
fois à cette loi est bien ce passage à
tabac de michel est clair écoutez je
commanderai moi j'ai pas eu le bénéfice
d'aller aux écoutes et se passer comme
ça la gênait on a la chance d'avoir des
gens qui contactent directement parce
que encore une fois comme souligné comme
je voulais dit la parole dans les
commissariats et vous voulez dans
les comédiens on peut pas tout dire se
sont pas des yeux de libre expression
donc l'expression la libre expression
les propos se tienne ailleurs et chez
vision on a la chance de recueillir
justement un certain nombre de propos de
gens qui sont indignés mais qui ont peur
de le faire savoir
parce que justement ils savent que vous
savez une actualité en chasse une autre
et que si aujourd'hui on condamne à
s'exposer à des représailles de la part
de l'administration demain et donc ça
c'est pas encore réglé donc il va
falloir travailler sur le long terme
pour pouvoir
j'ai de redonner naissance réformer la
police de façon à pouvoir avoir une
institution qui travaille avec éthique
et déontologie ce qui est loin d'être le
cas aujourd'hui donc c'est pas certes
majoritaire mais file trop merci
beaucoup
noam à anwar d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué syndical vigie police